pour juste un Trudeau et Christian
Freeland un objectif c'est un plan pour
aider les Canadiens avec le coût de la
vie démontrer qu'ils ont compris les
préoccupations des Canadiens nous savons
tous que nos amis et nos voisins
vulnérables subissent en cours les
conséquences de la hausse des prix une
onglise de mesure pour contrer
l'augmentation du coût de la vie
un crédit de tps appelé remboursement
pour l'épicerie pour les Canadiens à
faible revenu pouvant atteindre 467
dollars pour un couple avec deux enfants
ou du programme près de 2,5 milliards de
dollars
Ottawa annonce des assouplissements pour
les Canadiens qui ont de la difficulté à
rembourser leur hypothèque une banque
pourrait prolonger la période
d'amortissement d'un prêt même au-delà
de la barre des 25 ans
c'est que l'inflation continue de
diminuer et que les taux d'intérêt
baisse
autre mesure phare un nouveau régime de
soins dentaires comme le réclamait le
NPD il couvrira tous les Canadiens non
assurés dont le revenu familial est
inférieur à 90 000 dollars le programme
coûtera le double de ce qui était prévu
soit 13 milliards de dollars sur 50
milliards supplémentaires sur 10 ans
premier au province pour les soins de
santé
Ottawa présente sa riposte au Plan vert
massif américain nous veillerons à ce
que le Canada ces 6 l'occasion
historique qui se présente à nous 80
milliards sur 10 ans pour des crédits
d'impôts et des infrastructures vertes
le plan prévoit un crédit d'impôt
remboursable de 15% à l'électricité
propre qui pourrait servir à financer
des projets de société d'État comme
Hydro-Québec par exemple
Ottawa prévoit aussi un crédit d'impôt
de 30% pour la fabrication de
technologie propre qui pourrait
bénéficier au secteur des véhicules
électriques
est suffisant pour faire compétition aux
Américains difficile de le dire pour
l'instant l'espoir c'est que les
entreprises là vont regarder les coûts
la main d'oeuvre qualifiée les avantages
en termes de ressources du Canada puis
qui vont décider de devenir au Canada
l'état des finances publiques se
détériorent
Ottawa abandonne son objectif de retour
à l'équilibre budgétaire l'automne
dernier le gouvernement prévoyait un
surplus de 4,5 milliards en 2027-2028 il
anticipe maintenant difficile de 14
milliards l'année prochaine le déficit
va gonfler pour atteindre plus de 40
milliards de dollars le gouvernement a
de la difficulté à contrôler ses
dépenses selon cette expert on rajoute
des dépenses
sur de nouveaux programmes et que les
dépenses sont pas vraiment redescendu
autant qu'on aura peut-être plus espérer
après la pandémie le ministre a promis
de la prudence fiscale mais la réalité
la rattrape elle doit respecter les
volontés de son partenaire de danse le
NPD compétitionné avec le voisin
américain est composé avec un
ralentissement économique autant de
facteurs qui rendent sa cible de rigueur
budgétaire difficile à at teindre ici
Louis Blouin Radio-Canada Ottawa